even in the best of circumstances it's
confusing to be a 16 year old 18 year
old 20 year old guy everybody struggles
with their sexuality everybody struggles
with relationships everybody struggles
to build an identity and develop
self-esteem and that identity and to get
along with others and know how they're
going to fit into the world most of the
pickup advice prescribed generally it's
going to help you feel more confident
and help you get more sex but it's not
going to help your relationships and
it's not going to make you happy
you are now a movie star
um yeah I guess you know if we want to
put the bar that low for movie stardom
sure
yes yeah it's been a it's been an
interesting couple of years
um we were talking before we got started
about some of the Perils of success that
kind of come along for the ride what do
you think most people don't understand
about success
I think
people don't realize the
the more success you achieve and I think
it actually has more to do with the
velocity of success like I've talked to
a number of very very successful people
who became Successful by just kind of
compounding three to five percent per
year over like 30 years and they seem to
all be pretty mentally well adjusted
um those of us who go a little bit
cray-cray it's usually because that we
have like some sort of insane slope
um where it's like a 500 or a thousand
percent
increase uh within like a two to three
year period and um and that that seems
to be what messes with your head and you
know one one thing I've
said and known for a long time is that
identity lags Reality by a year or two
like you often run into people who lose
a bunch of weight for instance like they
lose 100 pounds
um they'll still
it will take a couple years for them to
realize that they're thin and I think
the same thing kind of happens with
success like if you blow up massively
in a six month period or a 12-month
period you spend like the next two years
kind of wondering what the hell happened
and where you are and why do all these
people want to talk to you and holy [__]
that's a lot of money I think I'll say
yes to it and then you regret saying yes
to it and it's there's just a lot of
psychological Fallout that I think
happens when you have that sort of
meteoric Rise you uh uh describing a
situation that I know pretty well at the
moment it's this weird combination of
imposter syndrome and excitement and
um anticipation for the future overwhelm
in terms of opportunity and uh yeah
there is no one that's going to give
sympathy to like oh my God your growth
is too too quick like let's let's all
get around a campfire and make you feel
better about yourself that's not going
to happen but it is a a concern and
we've heard for a long time about the
dangers of child actors you know the
Macaulay culkins of the world becoming
too big too fast as a kid but I think
that there's a a similar but even
potentially more difficult challenge for
adults to do with because your identity
has become locked you thought you knew
who you were and then something comes
along and actually rips you out of that
at least as a kid you're pretty
malleable and you won't be able to
remember a time that life wasn't like
you having a chef and security and a
private jet and stuff like that whereas
when it's changed you're so de-anchored
like unmode from whatever it was before
I think that that presents a new set of
challenges
yeah I well I think it's weird too
because
a kid doesn't know but like the kid
doesn't want it or doesn't really know
what they want it just kind of happens
to them
um I've actually found it I I'm not a
fan of his music at all but I've I've
found myself becoming very interested in
Justin Bieber's career or uh his
unwinding of his own career that I think
apparently within the last five years or
so he is just
canceled and undone tours and albums to
the point where he's just not working
anymore and I think he just sold his
entire music catalog for like 300
million dollars or something but it's
interesting because it to me that kind
of transmits this idea that like
he wanted to be famous when he was like
13. he didn't really understand what
that entailed and now that he's an adult
he's like wait I need to be a normal
human being and like get my head right
and have normal experiences
um I think for people like us it's
it's a slightly different experience
because you got what you wanted right
like you asked for this
yeah like this is the thing you've been
working for for like 10 years and
suddenly it's here and it's a lot more
stressful than you thought it would be
um it didn't solve a lot of the problems
you thought it would solve
there is that imposter syndrome
um everything that you do or say seems
to carry a lot more weight than it used
to
um you have something to lose now right
so you can't just like you know [__]
something out and throw it on the
internet and see what happens
um so yeah it is it is uh
it's this weird thing where you're like
I'm so grateful this is the best thing
that's ever happened to me but I'm also
so stressed out because
um I didn't realize that it would carry
this kind of mental weight with it yeah
terrified and holding on for dear life I
think I get this sense man it's it's so
strange when the channel blows up and we
have a particularly good period and the
way that YouTube works good periods we
get good periods and then you'll have a
little lull and then you'll come back
and it'll go absolutely bananas again
it's the number for me is around about
10 to 15 million plays a month when we
break that there is just this ambient
sense of anxiety that goes through me
and it's just me going I don't know
whether it's correlation or causation
but there's something that makes me feel
like
there are a lot more eyeballs on me than
I'm used to and as someone that's
naturally quite introverted that makes
me feel a bit like oh [__] like this is
good because it's reach but it's bad
because who are all of these people what
if I say something that was dumb more
second guessing more self-doubt what do
you think
um you you mentioned that success
doesn't fix the things that you thought
it was going to fix what have you found
for people that maybe are aspiring
towards success or looking toward
finding this inflection point of a
growth curve or whatever it is what are
the things that you found are good to
ground yourself in or where do you
continue to take your sense of Pride
Integrity personal self-worth from uh
that isn't the rapidly changing
ascending numbers and and revenue and
stuff like that
well I I think the most important thing
and at least the most important thing
for me is just been having a really
solid group of people in your life
um
and that's the other thing that's one of
the other things that changes with
success sometimes people around you
start behaving differently or treating
you differently and both in a positive
way and in a negative way and that
that's super weird to deal with but you
know ideally you have a a critical mass
number of people in your life that don't
give a [__]
you know how much money you make or how
how many people downloaded your last
episode or whatever like they just want
to hang out and drink a beer and watch
football
um
like like they always did and I I found
that incredibly like I found myself
craving that actually you know I would
go do a speaking tour
um go hang out with Will Smith meet a
bunch of crazy celebrities that
I always wanted to meet and then
you know make a bunch of money and I
would come home and I'd be like God I
just want to like see my old friends and
talk about totally unimportant stuff and
just goof around for for a week like
that that seems very nourishing uh
at those moments yeah I completely get
that I think uh it's very strange it's a
very very strange world when you can
achieve sort of status and Renown in a
very short period of time and I think
the interesting point around someone
that's iterated three or five percent
per year and has had time to Identity
lifestyle friendship groups everything
has just changed at around about the
pace that you can you know but if you
got to 20 per year perhaps you're
actually starting to lag behind a little
bit and that's a little bit too much
um one of the things that you also have
with this is
um high expectations so someone may have
very high uh demands of themselves they
want to perform very well they want
their work to have an impact they do
want to chase down this but commensurate
with that is this pain when you don't
achieve what you intended you know if
you want to hold yourself to a high
standard you immediately set an ideal
and then begin to compare yourself
against that ideal and inevitably for
the most part apart from the freak
best-selling book or whatever it is that
you do you're always going to fall short
have you considered how people could
deal with having high expectations
well I you know it's one of those things
I think there's a lot of situations
where certain mentalities or mindsets
that work
when you're not successful at all can
actually start working against you when
you become very successful so I think
that mentality is a perfect example you
know it's like when you've done nothing
I think it's probably very helpful to
set high expectations for yourself just
because it gets you working harder it
gets you expecting more of yourself
um I found that like once you start to
reach the peaks of a certain industry
maintaining those those
absurdly high expectations it just kind
of works against you it just makes you
you know it's like if I expected my my
next book to sell I don't know more
copies than Harry Potter like that that
that's absurd that's like a completely
absurd metric of success uh and I'm and
I'm like
pretty much guaranteed the fail so
um
I I think it's just you have to
the goal posts have to move and and not
only like through the goal posts have to
move but like maybe you even have to
find like a different field to set up
your goal post on than than you used to
because it's a lot of the same
measurements
uh that you use to get up the mountain
no longer make sense once you're
fairly high up on it yeah the tools that
got you here won't get you there is
something that I've thought about an
awful lot especially when it comes to uh
obsessing over little things
um not being prepared to delegate
control to other people not being able
to relinquish any of the neuroses that
you have around stuff it's like if you
want to do this you're going to have to
scale if you want to let go of this sort
of thing and um
yeah the strategies that get you from 0
to 50 are not the ones that are going to
get you from 90 to 95 or 95 to 96. yeah
yeah you say that the most important
question to ask yourself in life is what
pain do you want in your life and what
are you willing to struggle for why is
that the right question to ask
I think it's the right question because
anything worthwhile is going to require
some some degree of pain and struggle
and
um
and so if you're if you're oriented
towards the pain and struggle you're
you're probably going to be more aligned
with what you're capable of
accomplishing rather than if you just
Orient towards the pleasures I also just
think it's a much more interesting
question right like we all want the same
stuff more or less we all want to be
liked and make money and be popular and
be good at something
um
what what I think differentiates us as
individuals is is what sacrifices we're
willing to make and what challenges we
actually enjoy
um I used to say like
I you know I meet a lot of people who
tell me they want to it's probably like
I'm sure there's a million people who
tell you now that like they want to
start a podcast it's ever since my my
books blew up it's like everybody I
meet's like oh I want to write a book
I've got this great idea and then of
course you ask them have you started
writing and they're like oh no no no I
know I I need to like you know think
about it a little bit more and it's
I think at the end of the day most
people just don't enjoy sitting by
themselves in a quiet room
writing and rewriting and rewriting the
same paragraph like eight times and
I do for some reason like to me that's a
very
enjoyable afternoon and that's probably
why I'm a writer and most people are not
so that is the pain that you want in
your life or at least it's the pain that
you're willing to endure
yeah it's or you know another way to
frame it is kind of like what what is
the pain that what is the pain that
feels easy to you but seemingly nobody
else
like it it never I remember when I first
started blogging and I went to a couple
like the first couple like kind of
blogging or internet business events I
went to people would come up to me and
they'd be like man how do you how do you
write such long blog posts and I was
like what are you talking about and
they're like yeah I can't
I can't write like it's 500 400 500
Words a day and like I I'm tapped out
and meanwhile I'm writing like three
thousand four thousand five hundred five
thousand word posts
um every couple days and to me it never
even occurred to me that that was a lot
that was just kind of like what came out
when I sat down the right
um so I think it's very useful to look
for and discover the difficult things
that that come easily to you but don't
come easily to most people because
that's probably where your con
competitive Advantage is and that's
probably where you're you're most likely
to succeed yes I think the reality of
the lifestyle that you say that you want
is going to be very different from what
you see in other people so I remember
this example I think James Clear uses it
where he talks about what it's like to
be a rock star this is what it's like to
be a rock star from the outside is
playing this show in front of all of
these people and they're screaming your
name and you're making money and you're
with cool guy but the reality is 15
years living in a van with four friends
sleeping in the van with bloody fingers
putting super glue on with poor health
poor sleep habits not knowing if you're
going to make it stress being dragged by
a r and agents and all sorts of stuff
all over the place learning about mixing
and mastering and song playing and
desperately trying to go back over
chords again and again and again
yeah that's not what you see or the same
thing for Conor McGregor right you know
although he is now on a downward
trajectory I think he's kind of like one
of the most cringe people on the
internet right now but when he was at
the at the peak of his his coolness what
you saw was this like
[__] god this like Savant artist
manifest into physical form what you
didn't see was him living in the attic
of his parents house in Ireland
somewhere rolling the same combinations
and the same sequences over and over and
over again with no idea if it was going
to work out that's what the price that
you need to be willing to pay
yeah it's like every goal is like an
iceberg right like it's there's this
shiny beautiful thing on the surface and
then there's all this
difficult
hidden stuff underneath that uh is is
not apparent until you actually get into
it how come you got depressed after your
first book
um
I think it succeeded so
insanely highly
um that I honestly felt like I was like
there's no where do I go from here like
there's not
like for so many years my goals were
oriented around become a published
author become a bestseller
um
you know become known in in my industry
like a leading voice in my industry like
I spent probably half a decade with that
as like my map my mental map of what I
was working towards
and and then all those things are
achieved and
I think literally three to six months
after the book came out
um and then again the velocity or the
the intensity of the success was so
drastic that I I honestly was just
completely at a loss of what I should do
next for about six months and
I think
um you know depression at its core is a
sense of meaninglessness a sense of like
none of your actions matter and
so I you know because I was so oriented
towards those goals and I achieved like
not only did I achieve them I
obliterated them it just felt like until
I kind of found new goals or new
challenges for myself or a new map for
myself
um it just felt like anything I worked
on or did was pointless
gold medalist syndrome is kind of
similar and I think that yeah
Tom Brady is a really interesting
example of this you know as one of the
longest standing QBs of all time seven
championship rings or something like Tom
you only have 10 fingers like literally
you you know if if you have a good
couple of runs coming up and you manage
to stick your longevity you're gonna
have more championship rings than you do
fingers to put them on
it's I think athletes are always a
fascinating example of this
um something that's been your identity
your entire life you've been rewarded
psychologically socially financially to
such a massive extent and then you're
supposed to retire at like 36. you know
and you have the rest of your life good
luck let go of that identity yeah yeah
yeah have fun
um it's it's I can't even imagine
um you know the best description I heard
of this was uh
apparently Quincy Jones used to call it
altitude sickness and he would see it in
Young music artists that he worked with
that they would if they became too
successful too quickly he said that it
was like climbing a mountain
without acclimating on the way up and
that they would
basically develop altitude sickness and
then fall back down the mountain in
order in order to survive like sabotage
their their themselves to get back down
they would sooner have familiar failure
than unfamiliar success in a way exactly
exactly because it's just it's again
coming back to like how identity lags
reality like it's it's I think when that
separation between how you see yourself
and how the world sees you becomes too
massive
um it becomes untenable and you start
you probably find ways to sabotage to to
bring to bring that Gap closer together
just reflecting on my experience here
breaking the fourth wall a little bit
um I've certainly noticed within the
last
six to 18 months but certainly the last
six
um the way that people treat me is
different uh people that I've never met
before people that uh that I roughly
know or don't and um yeah the way that
it's it's becoming increasingly
difficult for me to work out whether
people have got my best interests at
heart whether they actually want to
spend time with me because they're
genuinely interested and they're a
well-meaning person or whether it's just
because they want to be associated with
someone they think is a rising stock and
um that's that's like a genuine uh
something that I've palpably noticed and
I think that you're probably right the
um analogy across to the person that
loses a lot of weight of it being around
about maybe one to two years that your
identity lags behind doesn't seem that
wrong
um yeah it's so the trust thing is super
interesting that is something that I've
experienced as well I'm much slower to
trust people than I used to be and and
it's exactly for the reason you said I
I've also noticed that I've developed a
pretty strong I call it like a fan radar
so there's a lot of people who like are
big fans but they don't obviously they
don't want to like Fanboy they they kind
of want to like come in under the radar
and like be friendly first and get to
know me and then
um you know be all casual about it and
I've noticed that I've I've kind of I
can be talking to somebody for like 10
seconds and I'm like oh this is a fan I
can tell this is a fan and sure enough
like two hours later they're like by the
way can you sign a book for me uh
I'll also say that that uh you know my
wife has got a very good [__]
detector and
she's been huge for me the last
five or six years
um just because just as an outside
Observer because you know when you're
when you're in an interaction with
somebody you know you like somebody they
seem cool you're you're having a good
time it's
it's very easy to miss things or Miss
details or misread flags and
um
you know having somebody like that who's
close to me who
that I that I trust very deeply you know
kind of pulled me aside and be like hey
I'm not sure about that guy like I think
he wants he wants something
um I mean this isn't to say that I I
some of my favorite connections that
I've made over the last few years have
been through the show for people that
listen because it becomes a gravity
Distortion well that attracts in other
people that are interested in the things
you're interested in which is great the
concern is people that maybe don't have
your best interests at heart and um I
haven't had my fingers burned by that
like super badly or whatever yet but it
is the sort of thing that I do get
quite conscious about speaking of
keeping yourself on the straight and
narrow you recently quit drinking
alcohol recently right yeah welcome to
the club welcome to the club thanks man
I actually I saw your video
I don't remember if it was right before
I quit or right after but it was you
know there was it was one of those
things where there was a series of
events over about two or three weeks
um I saw your video I saw the huberman
put out his podcast about alcohol which
was very eyebrow raising
um
had a couple conversations with friends
who had quit alcohol recently and and
then I had a personal event which
um
like I've I I've been I was a heavy
drinker pretty much my entire adult life
what does that what does heavy drinker
look like
uh I mean I was a party Hound right so I
anytime I went out
you know when I was younger any bar or
club or party I went to I drank a lot as
I got older that kind of turned more
into restaurants fine dining
um
trips vacations it was just alcohol for
me always if you took something fun
alcohol made it more fun and if you took
something boring it made it less boring
so
I I I pretty much always found some sort
of justification like you know it'd be
great right now a drink
um so
but it it it I think for me it hit and I
I'm a very functional drunk
um so I it never you know I know some
people have
it causes a lot of problems in their
personal professional lives
um
for me it it was always it never
interfered massively where it actually
started to interfere for me was in
physical health uh
I started getting a ton of weight
um
I went to a doctor got blood work done
the doctor was like
[__] this is the blood work of a this is
a blood work of a man like 30 years
older than you uh you might want to like
take a look at your habits
um
so all that was kind of going on the
background I I started losing weight
cleaning up my diet that also meant
drinking less and then
uh
and around this time I you know some
friends of mine were kind of
experimented with quit quitting drinking
uh I had hired a health coach who was
kind of encouraging me to
maybe give it up stop for three three
months or six months
and then I remember I went to an event
and it was event I signed up for and
paid for and
I ended up hanging out at the bar the
first night I ended up hanging out at
the bar with a few guys that I had met
and just got absolutely plastered like
just [__] shit-faced and I was so
drunk I couldn't I couldn't get up and
go to the event the next day and I
remember just laying in in bed in the
hotel room being like this is the
dumbest [__] thing like I paid
thousands of dollars to be here and I
feel so awful I can't even
I can't even be here right
um
so it was kind of in the air you know it
was percolating and
um so I gave I gave it up end of July
last year
initially I was gonna do three months
the three months was so amazing that I
was like okay I'm gonna go to the end of
the year
went to the end of the year drank it New
Year's just to see what it felt like
um
overrated and so my my goal for 23 is to
actually go do do all of 2023 without a
drink let's [__] go dude that's so
good it's the exact experience that I
had as well so throughout most of my 20s
running nightclubs thousand events stood
on the front door big party boy similar
to yourself and then I realized this
isn't really serving me again was
propelled by a very bad hangover one day
and thought right that I mean just this
the memory of this hangover will get me
through the first month and then I only
have another five to do after that
committed to six went back to drinking
didn't really like it all that much
wasn't very enamored with it found that
the progress I made when I was sober was
more addicting than the enjoyment of the
party when I went back to drinking came
back onto drinking did another six
months then thought right well I I must
have done my sobriety stint now I must
have got it all out of my system went
back to drinking for like a month and a
half and this is once every two weeks
this isn't me drinking consistently and
thought this sucks and then did a
thousand days and that was what I did
the the video about but yeah it is
such a game changer for a vestigial
party boy to go through because you just
open up all of this
consistency
time money calories to spend on things
that you genuinely care about energy
everything that you care to care about
in your life gets better when you go
sober and this is from two people who
had their drinking like relatively under
control right alcohol is the only drug
where if you don't do it people assume
you have a problem and the problem that
both of us had was lifestyle or
productivity slash Health based but it
wasn't dependency based so it's the
easiest of the letting goals you know
compared with almost everybody else that
attempts to go sober and if they can do
it we definitely can do it yeah for sure
and it I vastly underestimated
the effects it would have on my energy
my focus my motivation uh one of the
things that stood out to me that
huberman said in his his episode is he
said that if you've been a heavy drinker
and I think researchers Define heavy
drinker as I think it's 15 drinks a week
um which for some people is one night
out yeah right I'm like uh yeah that's
that's that's an average that was an
average week in my 20s uh he said at
least 15 drinks you know if you've been
a heavy drinker for
uh
multiple years
he said it can take six to 12 months for
the out for your system to actually
entirely reset for your brain to go back
to the way it was your internal organs
to go back to the way they were and I
was like God damn I've been doing this
basically since I was like 18 right like
so half my life almost two decades and
um
yeah it's incredible it's incredible it
was I'd say within a few weeks
waking up with more energy sleeping like
a baby
um
you know and one of the things you know
I had cut back quite a bit before I quit
completely I'd say I'd cut back to
drinking maybe two three times a month
and when I drank it was like just two or
three glasses of wine and it's funny
like something I feel like something you
notice when you cut back that you don't
notice when you keep drinking heavily
like when you drink heavily you just
expect to feel like [__] so when you
feel like [__] you're like oh yeah well
of course I drank I drank a lot but when
you drink very moderately
it actually showed me how much it
affects you like I would go out and have
two glasses of wine with dinner
and Not only would I feel
maybe 20 percent worse the next day I
would feel ten percent worse the day
after that and that was shocking to me I
was like whoa this is actually it's not
about hangovers it's about just
General lack of energy and motivation on
a day-to-day basis and it lasts for
multiple days so
yeah it's been an eye-opener I think
it's underrated I'm also
I feel like it's becoming a thing
um I'm
I've been really shocked and surprised
how many friends of mine who without
talking like people that I haven't seen
in six months
I hang out with them and they're like oh
I quit drinking by the way and I'm like
what me too holy [__] like that is
that's probably happened three or four
times just in the last year uh
completely spontaneously so I feel like
it's something that is becoming almost
trendy
um among
I guess people who care about
productivity and
accomplishing things so one of the
interesting things it would make a good
bit of sense for someone that's in their
30s like me and you perhaps to dial this
back especially if you're not going out
and trying to pull every night and going
to clubs and stuff right what is maybe
even more interesting is the trends that
I'm seeing amongst younger people people
who would have taken their sense of
self-worth from their degeneracy like me
and you might have done and even those
people even the Gen zetters are also
seeing going out and getting absolutely
lathered as
not exactly a high status
Pursuit
yeah it it's funny I've seen this a few
times on social media over the last few
years but I always find it amusing it
inevitably it's somebody posts a chart
and it's like
alcohol consumption uh sexual activity
maybe illicit drugs thrown in and it's a
chart of like Generations like how how
much each generation had done it by age
18 and it's it's a consistent Trend
downwards yeah
um
and gen Z does it the least of all they
the sex drugs and alcohol less than any
other generation before and the people
who post this chart they like complain
about the kids they're like wow kids are
so boring these days there's like on
their phone all the time they should get
out and have some real thoughts having
some heroin and unprotected sex come on
now kids where are you I'm like I'm like
wait a second when the hell did this
turn into a criticism like when I was
growing up it was it was you know
everything was like Don't drink don't do
drugs don't have sex and that's all we
wanted to do it's um it's really funny
how it's like somehow flipped almost
yeah I mean the behavior that me and my
housemates considered high status 15
years ago when I was at Uni would have
been how drunk you got the night before
whether you woke up in a bush if
somebody got an injury I actually did my
Master's dissertation on this it was the
effectiveness of anti-alcohol
advertising on students at Newcastle
University and what I discovered was
that a lot of students saw these
painful experiences as Badges of Honor
they were almost like a rite of passage
that everybody went through you know if
we were 21 year old Mark and 21 year old
Chris ring each other and say man how
was last night and you go dude it was
amazing John lost an eye and you're like
what like that would be that would be an
unironic
way that we would go about talking about
stuff and yet um Hamza who is a young
guy 24 25 I think British kid living out
in Dubai now YouTuber his whole thing is
do hard things especially when you don't
feel like it big in the nofap community
he's got this underground Fight Club
thing where he gets young boys to box
each other and this is the new sort of
hustle culture it's The Counter Culture
away from cheap dopamine and uh sort of
ease degenerate Behavior Uh so yeah like
the cool culture is always The Counter
Culture to whatever is the main culture
and for a long time degeneracy was so
mainstream that now it's come the other
side I don't even know
if a film like The Hangover would
resonate with young people anymore if
you were to release a movie like that
that's a good point yeah it's something
that I've been fascinated with recently
especially because I'm doing a lot more
on YouTube now and
obviously everybody on YouTube is young
as [__] so it's I'm like watching a
bunch of 24 year olds feeling like an
old man and it's so fascinating to me
because yeah it's what was cool my
entire Young Life what was cool was
destructive it was how [__] up can you
get what crazy thing can you do what
rule can you break and get away with it
um whereas it's
High status Behavior today at least
among a certain amount of the younger
generation it does seem to be very
productive like it's very uh you know
it's like study hacks and
um sleep habits and you know going to
the gym and no fap and all these things
like digital detoxes it's
it gives me hope it's funny I I found
myself I was at a
I was at like a a speaking at an event I
was at like a dinner with a bunch of the
VIPs or whatever and we were going
around I you know that Peter teal
question is like what do you believe is
true that most people don't yes
um
it was we went around the table we were
like going around the table and
everybody was giving their answer to
that and the answer I gave is I said not
only are the kids okay but they are so
much more impressive than you and I or
anybody was at their age
um and no for some reason nobody sees
this people just see Tick Tock and
they're like oh the kids are [__]
um you know they see the crazy woke
stuff going on on campuses and they're
like oh these kids they're brainwashed
and I don't know like I play a lot of
video games I spend a lot of time you
know I I post a lot on YouTube I have a
lot of young fans
um I spent a lot of time engaging with
Gen Z and I'm consistently very very
impressed by them do you think that that
could be selecting for the cohort of gen
Z that consume content like yours that
they will be the ones that will have an
idea about how to restrict their use of
tick tock and what they consume online
and stuff like that
I think so I think in the case of like
my fans but
um
I don't know even even when I when I get
on and and play games play video games
with a bunch of random kids like this I
hear the stuff they talk about or like
go on message boards and stuff go on
Reddit
um they're not calling you racial
epitaphs are they
or at least or at least way less often
than they did when I was when I was in
high school
yeah or or actually like so you know I
got kind of sucked back into online
gaming a few years ago and what are you
playing
uh well years ago I played a bunch of
OverWatch and
it I loved it it was especially because
it was kind of a throwback to my ear I
played a lot of quake and unreal when I
was growing up and so OverWatch was kind
of right right up my alley so I played a
lot with um a bunch of young people and
it was two things really blew me away
one was
um
first of all how many women there were
playing like openly too like when I back
when I played video games in the 90s it
was like if there was a girl she didn't
want anybody to know that she was a girl
like using the voice modulator to try it
yeah on the other side of a pillow yeah
or or just didn't you know no there was
no mic she used the boy's name you know
stuff like that so there are a lot of
there were a lot of women playing and
and the other thing that impressed me
too was just yeah obviously young people
are immature they're dumb but
and they say and do stupid things
embarrassing things but I was impressed
with the amount of kind of
self-regulation so you know inevitably
there would be some jackass who would
come in and say a bunch of racial
epithets and then everybody else who
just immediately mute that guy and it
was like problem solved no big argument
no like big drama no talking [__] I tell
you what I've become more and more
obsessed by recently is availability
bias on stuff that you've learned to do
with contentious topics so this weekend
one of my good friends a guy called
gwynda Bogle who's been on the show
three times he's on again next week he
just released an absolute monster of an
article about Tick Tock he put it out in
his sub stack and I managed to get it in
front of Rogan and then Rogan tweeted it
out which means that it reached like
three million people so his sub stack
just went berserk and this thing is a
[__] Masterpiece I'll send it to you
once we're done everyone that's watching
now will have already seen the video
that I put up with Zach where we talk
about it and we go through it
um but my most recent because that's the
most recent thing I read and it was so
compelling I'm currently in this state
of right okay how do we protect we need
some sort of guidelines maybe we should
do the same thing that the ccps and only
restrict access for 45 minutes a day you
can't open it between 10 p.m and 6 a.m
so that's my my current
leaning and yet I can't deny people that
uh gen Zed and watch your content or my
content or guys like Hamza who not only
speak to those kids but comes from that
world and is just completely flying one
and a half million Subs on Twitter
really really well regarded super
well-rounded guy
um
yeah I don't know I wonder whether
there's going to be
uh whether the Matthew principal is
going to come back in here and you're
going to have the Haves and the
have-nots the people who do have the
ability to deploy some self-control are
going to benefit so much more than the
people who can't because the people that
can't are going to be hijacked ever more
limbically by these new technologies by
the for you algorithm and stuff like
that
yeah I I think I mean look every
generation has its super talented people
who are very well adjusted and figured
things out very quickly and every
generation has it's people who lag
behind it's anti-social people people
who
you know get distracted or whatever
I I'm I'm always skeptical you know if
social media is such an easy scapegoat
for a lot of just general cultural
issues and I'm I'm always
my default position is to be very
skeptical of those things
um you know when I was growing up I used
to come home from school and watch TV
for six hours straight
and that was what I did from like age
seven to probably 10 or 11. TV and video
games like non-stop from the the moment
I got home from school until I went to
bed
I don't see how that's that much
different
than Tick Tock
um
and just in terms of constant
stimulation and distraction and you know
getting your your your entire sense of
culture from like a very
tiny sliver of Human Experience
I think these are things that just
they're just kids kids are very
distractible kids are very
easily seduced by crazy ideas and
charismatic people and then kids
generally grow out of those crazy ideas
and you know nine times out of ten they
grow out of those crazy ideas and
charismatic people uh and and so I I
just try to
remember that and hold some patience
um I personally think
I've been banging this drum for about a
year now and nobody listens to me nobody
cares but I I personally think Tick Tock
is vastly over Tick Tock might be the
most overrated thing in our culture
right now both in terms of its dangers
and in terms of
you know it's taking over Silicon Valley
or whatever the
the the thing is is Tick Tock kind of
puts up
it's like Tick Tock put some garbage
time minutes you know to use a sports
analogy Tick Tock is like that
basketball player who can score 60
points a game but never wins
um it's the videos are super short
there's a lot of Bot activity there's a
lot of kind of compulsive scrollers so
you get these very inflated numbers on
the platform and coming from a place
like YouTube or Facebook where content
is longer for them requires more time
energy
you see a tick tock video with like 800
million views and you're just like
that's [__] insane oh my God
everybody must be watching this but
they're not it's what what that is out
of those 800 million views it's
600 million people spent two to three
seconds and then immediately forgot
about it like when I use tick tock I'm
usually either
taking a [__] or like waiting in line
somewhere you know there's like a I've
got to wait five minutes for a bus to
come and I have nothing else to do in
those five minutes so I just get on Tick
Tock and I I'll watch 10 10 videos and I
will for as soon as I close the app I've
forgotten nine of those 10 videos I
don't remember who made them I don't
remember what they did or what they said
I may have chuckled once or twice
they're just so one of the things that
gwynda brings up in that article is
digital dementia which is a a term that
actually refers to this loss of gray
matter in the brain and it appears to be
facilitated by very passive short
iterative platforms like Tick Tock and
the precise reason that you can't
remember the stuff that you went through
if you were to ask me what the last four
videos were that I watched on YouTube I
probably could tell you I think I
watched a sunny V video about Joe
Rogan's biggest arguments that he's done
on his podcast I watched something from
most critical between him and Ludwig
about building a new Esports team
it's something else and something else
um at least when you spend sufficient
time and attention with a particular
topic it does force you to do a little
bit of recall so yeah although it may be
good in that the impact that it has on
you isn't so great you can't be
ideologically pushed uh you can be sort
of psychologically degraded
through this particular anyway I'm going
to send you it and I'm going to be
interested to know what you think so so
that that may be true that may be true
I'm not I'm not and and it's that may
turn out to be true
um
but just to wrap up my argument really
quick like I
it's empty calories you know
psychological side effects aside it's
empty calories it's advertisers are
discovering this where it's like you
can't get
people to leave like nobody buys
anything there nobody clicks off of it
um it's the views that are not they're
worth a thousandth of what of you on
Twitter or YouTube is worth
um creators like us are discovering that
views there are not worth anything so I
I just think
you know
we should chill a little bit wait a
little while and what you're saying
about the digital dementia it's like
okay if somebody if if their only media
consumption in their life is Tick Tock
for like 12 hours a day okay yeah that's
probably concerning there's probably
negative side effects to that but if
you're like watching Tick Tock for an
hour or two a day you're watching
Youtube for an hour you're watching a
movie a few times a week you're
listening to podcasts like you're
probably
it's fine
you have a media engine around you and
I've mentioned to you Offline that I'm
really impressed with the way that you
have this sort of cascade of single
pieces of content repurposed across lots
of platforms
for the people out there that are maybe
trying to do the same thing what is the
current prioritization list or the
hierarchy of
Mark Manson
capturing of audience members
well I I'm in I'm in a unique position
because I have built up
I have like 200 to 300 long form
articles over the last 12 years
that I've built a library out of you
know so that's probably
two to three books worth of written
content on my website and generally what
we do is and then I have a Weekly
Newsletter that is kind of new content
but generally what we do is we just find
ways to repurpose that old content for
whatever platform
we are posting on you know so Instagram
that might be a little uh
frame slideshow of
you know a three or four frame idea
Twitter might be a little tweet or a
quote
um
and then YouTube It's usually some video
format of one of the ideas from the
website so a lot of most of the work
I've been doing online in terms of just
audience generation and engagement it's
just been re taking that like massive
library that I spent 10 years building
and then just repurposing it
testing new ideas testing new versions
of old ideas uh in a bunch of different
places and kind of seeing what sticks
and what doesn't stick what's your
priority at the moment is it grow email
list is it grow YouTube is it accumulate
Instagram what is it
uh top priority right now is video so
I'm actually I just hired the first few
people on a video production team
um 2023 is basically completely blocked
off in my mind as like going all in on
video content
it's that's primarily there's two
reasons for that one is I think the
the only two mediums
in formats right now that aren't super
saturated uh
for scaling is podcasts and video and I
think even podcasts might have peaked
right now but there's probably still I
mean you're showing there's still
pockets and people can still climb
through but I mean in terms like written
con like blogs are dead uh it's if
you're trying to like build an audience
on Facebook or Instagram like your reach
is garbage
um it's just very it seems to be doing
okay some people seem to be growing okay
size sub stacks sub stack could be good
um I think it's it's very Niche
dependent
um so it's if you are especially if it's
politics related that seemed like if
you're an interesting voice in some
political topic you're probably always
going to find a way to break through but
for me I'm in an industry where anxiety
today is exactly the same as anxiety was
10 years ago there's nothing new to say
about it so it's
it gets very crowded or like and and
once you've kind of like stuck your flag
in it's going to be there for a long
time
um you know and I think I've done that
with a few topics James Clear has done
that with a few topics Ryan holiday's
done that with a few topics and it's
just
it's just going to be very hard to like
change that real estate
um in terms of of ideas and everything
so I'm
I'm excited and bullish on video content
I think there's it's still
underdeveloped as a as a medium online I
still think the audience is massive and
it's continuing to grow and it's and it
skews young so it's a lot of people
you know if you're if you're a 35 year
old or a 45 year old and you've been
online for a long time you've probably
heard that all the [__] that I have to
say or James clear as to say you've
probably heard like 20 times by now but
if you're 25 and you're on YouTube and
Tick Tock you probably haven't and
um so for me that's kind of where the
the Green Pastures are what are your
thoughts on the modern era of men's
advice because this is the industry that
originally originally originally you
were kind of born out of this not quite
pick apart history Maybe started there
then holistically moved into a more
balanced version of that uh and yet
there is always more opportunities for
men's advice to come around so how do
you see this new world of it
um
you know I see it as cyclical I think
every generation I mean self-help in
general is cyclical like these none of
these ideas are new it's just each
generation kind of needs to discover
them
and their own format and their own
language and I think the same is true
with
with a lot of men's advice I think you
know our generation it was the pickup
thing
uh the generation before that in the 90s
it was men's groups and sweat lodges and
iron John and things like that
um
this generation well let's say when it
was Jordan Peterson was was kind of like
the focal point I was
a little bit optimistic I thought I do
think he's an improvement on a lot of
men's you know advice geared towards men
uh
when Andrew Tate showed up I that
quickly turned to pessimism
[Music]
um
so I I don't know I feel like there's a
void right now I think there there
there's a void for like a really healthy
voice directed towards young men of how
to be how to manage yourself how to
develop yourself
somebody needs to step into that void
what are the memes that you keep seeing
coming back around are there any trends
that you see that from when you first
started out you're starting to see
resurface now
um
I will say that it is
surprised and impressed me how like the
staying power of the nofap thing I
remember when that started I think
around like 2010 2011.
I remember I experimented with it a
little bit and people like a bunch of
people jumped on that that train and
I don't know I I guess I assume that
there wasn't a whole lot there but it's
it's been impressive how much how it
stuck around it's interesting I feel
like this generation of men's advice
it's more about abstention I mean this
kind of comes back to an earlier point
about destruction versus productivity it
you know men's advice
in our generation you know when I was 20
years old it was all about
here's how to make all the money and
here's how to [__] all the girls and
here's how to go go to all the parties
and
this generation it seems a little bit
more like you should just
you know stop jerking off stop
distracting yourself stop eating garbage
um stop wasting your time
stop dealing with people who don't
respect you
and that it that seems to occupy a lot
more I mean there still is the make a
bunch of money and [__] a bunch of girls
like
like we're human there's always going to
be that but the physics of the system
yeah
yeah that seems like there's more real
estate given to the abstention side of
things which is which is very
interesting is there anything I I found
it very interesting to look at the
trajectory of the pickup slash dating
coaches from 10 to 20 years ago so I
spent
Thanksgiving with David D'Angelo in his
new form oh wow uh Neil Strauss yourself
took a Max are all people who came out
of a more use them and lose them
degeneracy party boy style
pick up world right uh Jeffrey Miller
even to to a lesser extent The
evolutionary psychologist you know and
yet I mean you look at particularly
David Neil and Tucker as guys that went
from being absolute degenerates to now
especially Neil almost like this sort of
Awakened Born Again sort of aligned kind
of guy David was showing off his
daughter to me at Thanksgiving and he's
just this sort of really holistic like
open-hearted guy took a Max you know
whatever it was five years of daily
Psychotherapy then into MDMA
Psychotherapy now he's living on a ranch
with four kids and 50 sheep and whatever
else it is that he does like what's
going on here what's happening with this
trajectory of of men that go from what
appears to be from the outside one
extreme to another
well I think some people just have
extreme personalities no matter what
their value system is and
you know I think William William James
had had an old quote where he said like
the only the only cure for addiction is
religion and
that's not to say that these guys have
like literally adopted religion I mean I
think in some I think Tucker has become
quite religious I'm not sure though
um
but yeah it's
I think a lot of us from that industry
exhibited a lot of compulsive Behavior
around parties women sex alcohol and
generally speaking it seems that that
compulsive personalities don't ever stop
being compulsive they just change the
focus of their compulsivity so it's in a
way it's not that surprising
it is interesting though I mean I see uh
a bunch of guys who
don't have theory of mind to be able to
project themselves forward into what
that person in the future would be like
and you know if 15 years ago either of
us had been tried to be convinced by the
older version of us that actually you
know when you grow up maybe these aren't
the things that you're going to take
your greater sense of self-worth from
would have just said [__] off [__] like
that's not I wasn't there to to listen
to it and I do I am in part concerned
that outlier guys who have very black
and white sort of mono thinking
strategies when it comes to this who
can't perceive a world in which anybody
that chooses to get into a monogamous
relationship isn't just settling
um are
um because of the like alluring
seductiveness of someone that has very
very clear parameters around this is the
way that relationships work this is the
way that men work and this is the way
that women work and that's just the way
it is and there is no room and no
caveats and no nothing else
they are outliers
and the problem that you have is if that
Cascades down you have a bunch of men
who perhaps don't have that same
mentality naturally or that same
predisposition then trying to retrofit
their lifestyle to somebody else's
preferences because they happen to be a
thought leader within the dating space
do you know what I mean
yeah yeah it's I mean look it's these
spaces
when you're young
it's confusing like trying to figure out
especially in this day and age right
like trying to figure out your sexuality
to begin with is
confusing trying to figure out dating
your dating life what you like in a
partner
um
how to actually get somebody attracted
to you these are all very confusing and
stressful things when you're young and
and
it's in a lot of cases the culture has
fed you a bunch of stories and
narratives that
are pretty obviously not always true and
so there's kind of this void
for some some other narrative or story
to step in and you know for us it was
kind of the pickup artist narrative and
I think for a lot of a lot of these the
young guys today it's it can be somebody
like Andrew Tate so like I empathize
like where like that situation and what
draws young men to a lot of these
explanations and stories I think what
inevitably happens and I think this
happened this happened in our industry
like my industry back
uh
uh 15 years ago and I imagine it's going
to happen again is that
you you take these kind of
counter-cultural narratives you know
this is the way men are this is the way
women are this is how you have to act
towards them this is what gets you laid
uh and you go you go try that out and
generally more often than not that
doesn't work either or maybe it works a
little bit in this one area but
it doesn't work in the others and I
think
generally kind of the
what most of the pickup advice
prescribed and I think what a lot of
what Kate prescribes it it's generally
it's going to
help you feel more confident and help
you get more sex but it's not going to
help your relationships and it's not
going to make you happy and so I think a
lot of guys have to experience that kind
of
shallow success like oh [__] I do have
more friends and I am going to more
parties and I did get laid a few times
but I
I'm not happy I don't have a girlfriend
I've like alienated some people I
haven't made any new friends this isn't
really like this this isn't really
working for me and then they kind of
start looking deeper at their own
emotional issues and what is right for
them and I think most of them at that
point kind of move on into into
healthier subjects there's a quote from
Naval ravacon where he says it is far
easier to achieve your material desires
than it is to renounce them and what he
means is that you know driving a beat up
Honda Accord is way simpler if your last
car was a Ferrari because you've closed
the loop right the zygonic effect is a
hell of a drug and if you can tick that
box and go oh I know what it's like to
[__] a Colombian chick like a fantastic
I now don't need to worry my Colombian
box has been filled or her Colombian box
has been filled perhaps yeah there you
go and the thing with the the reason
that I'm like first off me and Tate have
known each other for like maybe four or
five years now I think we've been
talking for for an all right while
the reason that I think he has been able
to fit in so effectively into the modern
discourse around men's advice is that
there is no alternative there is a huge
huge void and for all the uh Peterson is
someone that I consider a [__]
unbelievably valuable and important
influence in my life and also someone
that I hold as a friend he has abandoned
those talking points recently I haven't
heard him create any new stuff the last
time I heard him talk about this
in all of last year he did Alex's show
and he did mine and those were the only
two times that I really got anything
about the sort of existential philosophy
depth of suffering and life type thing
very much now he's concerned about uh
broad scale social problems
environmental change culture overreach
and Academia blah blah blah they very
well may be more valuable things in his
eyes for him to spend his time on but
for young guys that there is a void and
wherever there is a void someone will
get sucked in and for every single
person from the left that has an issue
with Andrew Tate being the new role
model for guys in 2023 please show me
your alternative like if you do not
speak to men they will find someone that
speaks to them and right now you have a
very well spoken regardless of what you
think of him his ability to speak is
[__] 10 out of 10 170 IQ verbal
agility
how could he have never how could he
have not been successful in this world
yeah and this is the this is the thing
you know because we had a lot of
I mean I'll just call it kind of toxic
male advice back in the pickup days but
the thing is is the guys who are giving
it were like weird dweebie guys with
like feather boas and top hats
um the thing about Tate is he if you're
a 16 year old kid you look at a video of
him and he just looks [__] cool like
you're like dude that's a cool [__]
guy he drives a Lambo he's got a bunch
of money he's banging girls he's a
kickboxer like so I get the appeal I
just you know and I've been saying the
same thing a lot of people have been
I've been doing a lot of traditional
media for the for the for the film and a
lot of them have been asking me about
Tate because of my background and I keep
saying exactly what you're saying is I
say look
it is
even in the best of circumstances it's
confusing to be a 16 year old 18 year
old 20 year old guy like it's everybody
struggles with their sexuality everybody
struggles with relationships everybody
struggles to build an identity and
develop self-esteem in that identity and
to get along with others and know how
they're going to fit into the world and
know how they're going to find a
relationship
it's a very difficult thing for for
everybody including young men and
I said that the correct question isn't
like why is Andrew Tate saying such
awful things the question is is like why
are so many young men listening to him
it what is appealing about him what is
drawing all these young men towards him
and why it isn't there as you said a
better alternative
um
I do think too I mean it's it has to be
said like I
I just think it's intellectually
dishonest to not say
even if you believe a lot a lot of the
social changes that have happened over
the last five or ten years are good you
know things like me too and some of the
work movement
you have to admit that that adds
confusion to young men like if if you're
a 18 year old guy and you grew up
watching me too happen and all the stuff
that your dad told you to do five years
ago is now deemed offensive
uh
that's confusing as [__] like how do you
sort that out in your young head
you know without without you know and
especially with all the consequences and
cancel culture and stuff that's going on
so I I just think
um
again I I
hope for a a healthier more integrated
men's voice to to start appealing to
these young guys and I do think somebody
will eventually come along
um
but it's it's it's definitely a massive
Gap in the social fabric at the moment
but let me give you this with regards to
how me too could have hurt and Confused
young girls approaches as well so for
almost all of recent history when it
came to dating advice for women which
they do actually have apparently there
is an industry of that
um yeah a very large one yeah
significantly larger than it is for men
um why men love [__] treat him like
you don't like him all of this advice
told women that the way to get a guy to
be interested in you was actually to
pull away but then in a post metoo world
guys who see a girl that plays hard to
get thinks oh [__] I do not want to get
canceled I'd better avoid this situation
at all costs and yet girls I don't think
have updated their operating procedure
in order to account for this new
hypersensitivity that guys have around
anything short of a [__] yes being an
absolutely not get away from me or are
you gonna end up on the front page of a
newspaper
yeah and it's I think
this is why not to toot my own horn but
you know for people who don't know
I I made my name in the pickup industry
by promoting
a philosophy of just blunt and radical
honesty in dating situations
and
I think that's more important than ever
like it you just Express how you're
feeling express your desires but express
it in a way that's respectful of the
other person and be always be willing to
hear no and accept no
um
I just think at the at the fundamental
core of all dating romantic
relationships you have to have that
clear line of communication from the
get-go and I think given all the
cultural confusion and mixed messages
around this stuff
um it's probably more important than
ever what do you think most people
misunderstand about how relationships
work
I think they they think it's a game they
they conceptualize it in ways that
ultimately boil down to a power struggle
so this could be anything from you know
oh wait a day to text her back so she
you know
she doesn't think you like her too much
to
uh pulling up old arguments you know
like let's say my wife and I get in a
fight and then I'm starting to lose that
fight and so I pull up something that
she did six months ago to like score a
point I wrote an article about this uh
it was called like 10 or six toxic
habits ticks you can't talk man uh six
toxic relationship habits that most
people think are are normal and one of
them I called it the relationship
scoreboard basically people who keep
score track responses track time
um you know people who get upset of like
well I called you twice and you never
called me back like it's if you're
counting [__] like that like you're
already losing just from the fact that
you're counting
some people's nature is that though
right some people will struggle due to
feelings of insufficiency anxious
attachment just general concern about
their partner they'll think oh well how
many times should I call them back maybe
if I do message them too quickly then
they're not going to like me what do you
say to that person
it's hard because I think two
communicate honestly you have to sort
through your owns and insecurities and
this is ultimately what you know I wrote
a book
uh it's called models attract women
through honesty and and ultimately the
core of the book is that
honesty always wins but
to actually be able to live that you
have to sort through your own [__] and
and often that process of sorting
through your own [__]
it results in short-term failures you
know uh so it's to that anxious person
with anxious attachment
um
you ultimately want them to communicate
how they're feeling
in a very unconditional way but the
first few times that they do that
they're going to come on way too strong
and it's going to create it's probably
going to scare people away or it's gonna
cause them to not be attracted to them
anymore
uh but I think you have to kind of go
through that experience to understand
where the line is of of like okay where
does honest communication end and then
my insecurities begin
um to kind of get a sense of like how to
healthily communicate in the future yeah
I think a lot of insecurity in people
around their own self-worth then get
born out when a relationship happens
because for the most part
all of your foibles and concerns and
everything else you can hide them away
brush them under the rug you know you
have that thought pattern every single
day and you do some Buddhism mindfulness
exercise thing where you sort of let go
and allow and it just [__] off you know
I'll deal with that manyana Manana
Manana and then before you know it it's
five or ten years later but there are so
few places to hide when you start
spending time with somebody else and you
get that compulsion of companionates or
passionate attachment to someone and you
go okay all of that stuff that was under
the rug has now congealed into a dust
monster and it is just running ravage
around in my mind and you can no longer
hide it and this is why I like your
Insight around doing the self work
before you then even expect to have a
particularly healthy relationship and
it's also presumably why
people see these same problems in all of
their relationships you are the common
denominator between all of your
different relationships and if every
single partner that you get with is just
way too distant or way too needy or way
too overbearing or way to whatever it's
like they have nothing in common with
each other except exactly for you you're
the only thing that they have in common
yeah and and again this is why
honest communication disclosure is so
important you know I get I get a lot of
questions from guys who say stuff like
that they're like well I I tend to be
very anxious and clingy and I struggle
with that like what should I do and I'm
like well when you start dating somebody
just calmly let them know like hey I
have a tendency to be a little clingy if
it ever starts to put you off just let
me know and I'll back off
you know like ask your partner to help
you regulate your own boundaries
understand where the line is
um so that you can adjust your behavior
accordingly like not only is that the
most effective thing to do but it re you
now you don't have to spend weeks and
weeks or months and months like hiding
this horrible thing inside yourself that
you think is gonna get you rejected by
somebody
there's something called the
Michelangelo effect which I learned
about a little while ago which is over
time in a relationship each partner
begins to look more and more like the
other partner's idealized version of
them and the reason it's the
Michelangelo is that from a rough hewn
block of marble over time it gets
chipped away to look like the vision
that the artist had and that's the best
way that you could have a relationship
right that you are going to help me
become not only more of me but I am
going to be more of the type of person
that you would like and hopefully your
desire for the type of partner will make
me even better than I could have been on
my own but again that is all mediated by
being able to tell the truth by not
coming across as being too needy and you
had a tweet last year that I loved that
said uh nobody remembers your mistakes
as much as you do and I think that that
level of self
um concern and self-doubt is because of
that right that you have this
front row seat to every mistake that you
make as you fall flat on your face over
and over again and even the person
that's the closest to you probably can't
even remember the thing that you did
yesterday that you felt like was this
huge embarrassing episode
yeah it's because everybody else is too
busy worried about their mistakes
everybody is paying attention to
[Music]
um as a guy who is now 38 you know 38 38
what do men have to focus on at 38 that
they didn't have to focus on at 28.
it's a great question uh for me the most
obvious I mean and this is a lot of this
is
personal but I think
physical health is the biggest one
um
Tim Ferriss actually said it perfectly
with when I talked to him he said that
it's as you age the amount of focus and
attention you have to give your physical
health does not increase linearly with
your age it increases exponentially and
I've definitely found that to be true it
it is
shocking and upsetting how many habits I
had in my 20s that I thought were okay
you know by 35 are actually causing
significant problems in my life
um so I you know I think health is the
biggest one by far I do think
um
you know the nice thing that happens
when you age is
you've had enough experiences
and enough time has passed
like I think a lot of kind of the dumb
stuff that we do when we're young is
simply the fact that we not enough time
has passed for us to realize how much
our values change over the course of Our
Lives
and so when you're young if something
feels important you you kind of just
naively assume it's going to be
important forever
and once you get to your your 30s and
probably more so in your 40s you've
lived enough to see that like oh yeah
that thing that seemed really important
12 years ago
I realized didn't matter six years ago
and there's like a fluidity that comes
in and out with your prioritizations and
um you know friendships that you thought
were
the most important friendships in your
life they come and go and you realize
that life goes on and it's okay and you
meet new people
um so it's almost like this this
kind of like existential fluidity that
starts to happen with the things in your
life I guess that's called wisdom or
it's another name for wisdom but um
it's I think it's underrated like I
really appreciate that about aging and
again it's something nobody really
tells you it's gonna happen yes
perspective
the ability to have that perspective I
dude I remember even now I I find it the
same I just presume the thing that I'm
obsessed by now will be the thing that
I'm obsessed by for the rest of time and
you know even when I started this show
which was five years ago I was so deep
into the productivity space that was my
thing I thought I would just do endless
numbers of episodes about the Pomodoro
Technique or procrastination or mono
thinking or monotasking or whatever and
then after a little while you realize
okay like maybe the friendships I had
are going to drop away and you know I
know that you moved to was it Brazil or
somewhere you just kind of dropped
everything and went I think when you
make decisions like that which I did
last year to go from the UK to Austin
it that's a nice sort of landmark flag
in the ground a very formative
experience that reminds you well
maybe things aren't always going to be
the way that they were and maybe I'm not
always going to be obsessed and maybe my
friends aren't always going to be there
and also as you grow older people are
going to start passing you know
situations are going to change
um I realized this only the other day
that I think you'll be Episode 600 or
something of this show
pretty soon there's going to be people
that I had a conversation with for an
hour that I really really enjoyed and
they're not going to be here anymore I'm
I'm gonna have I don't know an ever
increasing number of posts that I'm
gonna have to write or mornings that I'm
gonna have to deal with
where I wake up and go holy [__] that
guy or girl that I really loved spending
an afternoon with is
gone so yeah all of this as you grow
older does remind you
um stuff doesn't last forever including
your obsessions and including your
thought thought processes
it's interesting related to that I have
found
I how much more aware I am of the time I
have left
again I think when you're when you're 20
something
use your whole life ahead of you it
seems like forever and
you know coming up on 40 I've now
experienced how quickly 10 years goes by
and and how many things you wanted to do
in those 10 years you never never got
around to doing or tried to do and
weren't able to do
um and so it's
again back to the perspective thing
um it's really given me appreciation for
like okay you've probably got 25 to 35
years left of a career
and that's not that does not feel like
that much time anymore and so you have
to be very very conscious of like how
you're investing each year how you're
spending each month
um and and kind of bringing this full
circle back to the the The Perils of too
much success too soon
um that's been helping me a lot to say
no to things
is is remembering like
look man like it's
you've got you've got 20 25 Peak years
left like don't waste them you're you're
almost halfway through your professional
life so make the last half count
um don't make the same mistakes you made
coming up the first half so that that's
kind of been where my mentality has been
at what can people expect from you next
uh so there will be a lot of video
content coming primarily on YouTube over
the next year
um I'm hoping to I've actually got a
video going up
this weekend where I make I guess a a
bold intention which is to reinvent the
self-help space on YouTube
um I've got some ideas for new formats
and
involving the audience uh in real life
situations so I'm very excited about
that I think it's
it's an opportunity to do something very
new and big and
bold so that's getting that's getting me
very excited unreal why can people go to
check out everything else that you do
uh markmanson.net's the website I've got
the Breakthrough newsletter there I'm on
every social platform For Better or
Worse
um but yeah the new the new stuff will
be primarily on YouTube thank you I
appreciate you dude
thanks Ben it's a pleasure what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]